justin here with a gamespot news update
popular crowdfunded gained star citizen
has finally passed 1 million
contributors the campaign began in
October 2012 and has raised over 92
million dollars over the last three
years creator chris Roberts said
previously that he expects star
citizen's crowdfunding to hit 100
million dollars at this rate it'll
probably hit that milestone by the end
of the year star citizen surpassed 1
million backers shortly after citizen
Khan a fan event dedicated to the game
at the gathering developer cloud
imperium games made a number of
announcements including casting details
for star citizens campaign mode squadron
42 well known actors Gary Oldman Mark
Hamill gillian anderson andy serkis ben
mendelsohn and mark Strong will appear
in the game Oldman's character Admiral
Bishop gives an emotional speech during
the game's opening cinematic no release
date for star citizen has been announced
are you one of star citizen's 1 million
backers for more news reviews and
previews stay tuned to gamespot com